[MUSIC]
When we're talking about how leaders can
manage emotions in times of crisis, it's
very important to first understand what
we mean by manage and what we don't mean.
Managing emotions means,
let's say, regulating emotions.
It absolutely does not
mean suppressing emotions.
The process of trying to suppress
an emotion is something we can do for
a short period of time,
but not indefinitely.
It's very difficult, it drains us,
it takes a lot of energy,
it can actually be
counterproductive as well.
The act of seeking to suppress an emotion
can exacerbate it, can heighten it,
can remind us of the fact that
we're feeling something and
it can come kind of roaring out at a time.
So if we think of managing emotions
as seeking to regulate emotions,
a couple of ways to address that.
One is learning a little bit more
about our emotional tendencies and
how are we likely to respond
in certain circumstances.
Sometimes that's very tactical.
I know that I'm about to
go into a conversation or
a situation that I typically
experience as somewhat triggering.
And let me just sort of prepare myself for
that, let me ensure that my calendar is
a little bit clearer both before and
after this particular interaction.
If I've got a particularly difficult
conversation or interaction,
make sure I'm getting a good night's
sleep in advance, things like that.
There's also stuff that we can do
in the moment, that leaders can do,
to regulate and manage emotions
more effectively in the moment.
Some of that simply entails
ensuring that we're framing
the situation in a way that's going to be
most useful for our emotional response.
Framing or cognitive appraisal in the sort
of term of art that psychologists
use relates to the meanings that we
are assigning to a given situation,
to a given set of circumstances.
Am I assuming that this is
going to be a hostile interaction,
this is going to be contentious?
And if so, what am I basing that on?
Is that necessarily accurate or
am I just making some assumptions here?
A more common term that we use in my field
as an executive coach is mental models.
The mental models are basically the set of
assumptions that we make about the world
around us to help us make sense of the
world and navigate it more effectively.
These models are largely accurate,
that's how we get through the day.
And they're less accurate
in certain circumstances,
they're less accurate under stress.
And can we step back and actually say,
well, what are my mental models?
What are the assumptions and
interpretations that I'm
bringing to the situation?
And if they're not useful,
can I reframe the situation?
And then we can take a number of steps to
build our capacity to regulate emotion
over time.
The cheesy acronym that I use in my
class at the GSB is messy, M-E-S-S.
If we can commit to
a mindfulness practice, and
meditation is the single most
effective kind of tool in that regard.
There are a number of other
ways to pursue mindfulness,
going on a reflective walk,
some forms of exercise.
E for exercise, if we can get some
consistent, regular physical activity.
S for sleep,
if we can get regular amounts of sleep and
sufficient amounts of sleep and
higher quality amounts of sleep.
And second S for chronic stress.
If we can identify sources of chronic
stress in our life and diminish them,
we're going to be much more effective
at emotion regulation in those moments
when we need it most.
[MUSIC]
So under stressful conditions, like those
that we're living on a day-to-day basis
in the COVID-19 era, we often experience
what's known as a threat response,
or a fight, flight or freeze response.
And under those conditions,
one of the ways that it manifests itself
is this sense of urgency,
the need to hurry up.
And although in certain circumstances
that's actually quite useful,
because obviously we evolve this
response in a way to help us survive.
The dilemma is that very rarely these
days do we experience a literal threat
to our physical safety that requires
an immediate physical response.
We often experience a situation that
we interpret as a threat to our
physical safety and
we speed up in response to it.
And that speed, that sense of urgency
is actually counterproductive.
So the impulse to hurry should, I think,
often be interpreted as
a signal to slow down.
If we can train ourselves to
interrogate that sense of urgency and
ask ourselves, is that really useful here?
Is it really going to be helpful here?
Or is it going to spur me to potentially
some counterproductive action?
And remind ourselves to slow down and
assess what's happening a little
bit more deliberately, we're likely to
navigate the situation more effectively.
[MUSIC]
I often work with professionals,
with the leaders of my practice,
are going through some kind
of transitional phase.
And we often have a negative
emotional response to endings.
This is kind of reflected in a line
from an old Tom Cruise movie Cocktail.
Tom Cruise plays a bartender, and
in that movie, he says at one point,
everything ends badly,
otherwise it would never end.
And there's some truth to that,
because endings,
in some sense,
they're all symbolic deaths.
They remind us that this
existence will end.
And whatever we believe about
what transcends this existence,
we're very attached to this existence.
And it could be quite dislocating,
it could be unnerving to
be reminded of that ending.
And yet, I would suggest that our negative
emotional response to endings leads us to
kind of lean away from endings
as opposed to leaning into them.
And we thus miss opportunities to
practice, to really gain something from
each ending and learn something from it,
that would help us prepare for
the much larger series of endings that we
will encounter over the rest of our lives.
I'm reminded of a line from Nietzsche,
that also seems very relevant here.
The end of a melody is not its goal,
nonetheless,
had the melody not reached its end it
would not have attained its goal either.
And I think that's true for
every experience we find ourselves in.
It's true for the course that I teach.
The end of the class is not the point,
but if we hadn't reached the end,
we wouldn't have gained the experience.
It's true for
the students that I work with.
The end of graduate school is not the
point, but if they didn't reach the end,
they wouldn't have achieved the goal.
And I think we can apply that in
a much larger philosophical or
even spiritual sense to our lives.
Obviously, the point of a life
is not to reach the ending.
And yet, if we hadn't reached the ending,
if this existence weren't finite in some
sense, I don't believe that it would
have the same sense of meaning.
So I believe that it's important for
us to acknowledge
the finite nature of all experience,
and in some sense, recognize and
lean into the very uncomfortable,
unnerving emotions that that stirs up.
In part because it's good practice,
it helps us extract something
that we can learn from.
It helps us learn something from every
experience that ends in a way of
preparing us for
the larger endings that are to come.
[MUSIC]